Bitte, Herr.
Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Aligje und ich bin als Assistent auf dieser Station tätig.
Ich würde gerne jetzt mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Tag.
Also, ich benötige Ihre Personendaten. Könnten Sie mir Ihre Namen und Nachnamen nennen?
Ich glaube, Sie haben meinen Namen schon, aber ich kann es Ihnen gerne nochmal sagen.
Ja, bitte.
Mein Name ist Christine Osehn.
Also, Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname muss stabilieren?
Natürlich. Das bekomme ich immer gesagt. Osehn kommt aus dem französischen.
Otto Zeppelin Anton. Ida Nordpol Emi.
Okay. Also, Christine endet mit E, oder?
Ja, mit E. Christine Osehn.
Frau Osehn.
Osehn, bitte Sie, das richtig auszusprechen.
Wenn Sie mich schon untersuchen, dann berichten Sie, Doktor.
Wenn Sie meinen Namen aussprechen können, dann brauche ich hier gar nichts zu kommen.
Dann gehe ich woanders hin, Doktor.
Ja, ich beachte Ihre Namen richtig nennen. Können Sie wiederholen?
Wie lautet man?
Osehn. Osehn, ja.
Osehn, genau.
Danke. Wie alt sind Sie denn, Frau Osehn?
Ist das so wichtig, meinen Alter zu fragen?
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Okay, ich bin 72 Jahre alt.
Ja, und wann wurden Sie ganz genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 25. April 1950.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Bitte, ich habe Ihre Frage nicht verstanden.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ach, kurz, Sie wollen Sachen wissen, Herr Doktor.
Ich bin ungefähr 72 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Vielen Dank für diese Information.
Frau Osehn, was kann ich für so tun?
Was fürstet Sie uns?
Also ich habe jetzt ein Problem, Herr Doktor.
Das macht mir so ein bisschen Angst.
Und ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll.
Ich war jetzt bei verschiedenen Ärzten, aber die fand ich nicht so gut.
Und man hat mir empfohlen, hier bei Ihnen zu schauen.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Ja, gerne.
Das sind Probleme, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sagen soll.
Immer sehr unterschiedlich.
Und kommt manchmal mehr, manchmal weniger.
Aber schon sehr komisch, muss ich sagen.
Aber ich werde es Ihnen erzählen.
Meistens, wenn ich laufe,
bekomme ich so Schmerzen in beiden Beinen.
Und ich kann dann manchmal nicht stehen
und habe das Gefühl, ich falle gleich hin.
Ich muss mich dann gleich hinsetzen
und ein paar Minuten meine Pause machen.
Ich verstehe.
Es sind mehr die Schmerzen, die mich sehr bei Unruhe gehen.
Außer einerseits, wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ich glaube, das geht schon seit Jahren,
aber ich habe es nie richtig beachtet.
Können Sie mir beschreiben,
wie die Beschwerden auftreten sind?
Ich habe es Ihnen gerade eben gesagt.
Ich habe es früher sehr oft gemacht.
Wenn Sie ruhig oder setzen,
haben Sie auch eine schwere Beschwerde?
Nein, da habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Nur wenn ich laufe.
Frau Ossene.
Sie können mir die Schmerzen beschreiben.
Ist eine drückende oder drückende Beschwerde?
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Das fängt von der Bauchnabel an,
vom Beckenseifel,
auf beiden Seifen straht, in beide Beine aus.
Das ist ein komisches Druckgefühl,
Schmerzgefühl.
Ich kann es nicht beschreiben.
In beide Richtungen.
Es geht um die Schmerzen.
Es geht manchmal runter bis zum Fuß.
Es kommt meistens, wenn ich laufe.
Eine längere Strecke.
Haben Sie belegt,
dass Ihre Haut sich Farbe verändert?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich musste immer meine Hose runterziehen.
Das habe ich nicht gemacht.
Es sind mehr die Schmerzen.
Ich habe nicht draußen laufe.
Haben Sie auch gefallen,
dass Ihre Beinschwellungen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Verlässe in der Lestezeit?
Nein, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Frau Ossene.
Herr Doktor, so langsam sollten Sie meinen Namen richtig aussprechen.
Das ist ein bisschen schwer zu sagen.
Frau Ossene.
Haben Sie Fieber, Schütterfrost?
Nein, das habe ich alles nicht.
Das sind nur die Schmerzen.
Das ist ein komisches Druckgefühl.
Das ist ein dummes Gefühl.
Wenn ich mich ein paar Minuten hinsetze,
dann ist es wieder weg.
Dann kann ich wieder laufen.
Aber dann kommt es wieder.
Hat sich Ihre Appetit verhandelt?
Nein.
Haben Sie geblieben?
Haben Sie Gehwicht in der Lestezeit?
Nein.
Nein, Ansicht nicht.
Mein Gewicht ist gleich geblieben.
Da hat sich nichts geändert.
Der Höhen will ich vielleicht ein paar Kilo abnehmen.
Aber leider nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Schulgang?
Oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Manchmal bekomme ich auch mal leichte Verstopfungen.
Aber da habe ich meine Mittel.
Wie ich das lösen kann.
Das klappt gut.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas ein?
Nein, ich nehme Zweckchen.
Manchmal auch Trockenobst.
Es gibt auch Flosamen.
Aber ich habe nicht.
Ich habe nicht.
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Ich habe noch nicht.
Frau Ösing.
Ja.
Ich habe nicht.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Haben Sie schon mal geraucht?
Ich habe früher mal geraucht, circa 20 Jahre.
Aber ich habe dann aufgehört.
Was haben Sie geraucht?
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Circa 20 Jahre, wie ich schon sagte.
Und es waren Zigaretten.
Ungefähr eine Schachtel am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol.
Nicht so viel, aber ab und zu mal.
Ab und zu mal.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Nicht täglich.
Ein, zwei Mal die Woche zum Abendessen.
Ein Gläschen Rotwein.
Das ist eine Rokinoprage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Drogen?
Was meinen Sie mit Drogen?
Drogen, ja.
Hast du das?
Sie wollen eine ehrliche Antwort?
Diese Frage muss ich Ihnen stellen.
Das muss in der Akte sein.
Es bleibt unter uns.
Es erfährt kein anderer, oder?
Nein, ich verrate.
Als Student habe ich einiges ausprobiert.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Frau Ölzehn.
Leider.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Leiden Sie unter irgendwelche chronischen
oder wichtigen Krankheiten,
dass ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel
im Bluthoch-Rok, Sückerkrankheit
oder Schiffdröße?
Nein, da habe ich nichts.
Aber letztes Jahr wurde bei mir eine Rheuma-Erkrankung
festgestellt.
Das ist ein Krestsymorm.
Er wollte mir gleich Medikamente
und Spritzen geben.
Ich wollte nichts haben.
Ich warte erst mal ab.
Wissen Sie den Namen nicht?
Doch, Methodrexat war das.
Aber ich wollte nichts.
Ich habe da schlimme Sachen gelesen
und habe keine.
Wie hoch müssen Sie diese Spritze einnehmen?
Das waren Spritzen.
Ich nehme es nicht.
Seitdem nehmen Sie nicht?
Nein, ich habe Ihnen gesagt.
Die Rheumatologe wollte mir diese Medikamente geben.
Aber ich will es nicht.
Ich nehme es nicht.
Was ist sonst noch?
Außer Rheuma?
Nein, sonst habe ich nichts.
Wo ist das?
Meine Galenblase ist entfernt worden.
Wann war das?
Herr Osana,
waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Oder haben Sie eine lange Reise gemacht?
Nein, nein.
Ich war einig immer hier.
Haben Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ich meine auch Corona her.
Gegen Corona.
Ich bin ein Gegner der Impfung.
Ich habe bisher keine Impfung.
Ich will das nicht.
Aber ich hatte einmal eine Covid-Infektion.
Wann war das?
Das war ungefähr einem Jahr.
Auch Örsehen.
Solange wird das?
Örsehen.
Ich laute die Corona-Infektion.
Sie sprechen es schon besser aus.
Reagieren Sie allegig auf etwas?
Ausstauschen?
Medikamente?
Nein.
Sie treiben sich vor?
Ich bin gerne gewandert.
Aber anderen Sport mache ich nicht.
Frau Örse, noch eine Frage.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, meine Eltern sind leider schon verstorben.
Woran hat sie gestorben?
Woran sind sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte einen Herz infarkt.
Meine Mutter hatte leider Brustkrebs.
Darum ist sie gestorben.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund.
Sie sind verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin verwitvet.
Mein Mann ist vor 5 Jahren verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Sie sind Rentnerin.
Was haben Sie vorher gerne?
Ich war Managerin für die
Außendienst in einem großen Elektro-Unternehmen.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Frau Örse, ich gucke mal, was ich vergessen habe.
Schlimmes oder muss ich Angst haben?
Ich habe keine Angst.
Das ist etwas Schlimmes.
Das haben Sie überhaupt noch nicht untersucht?
Ich habe keine Angst.
Ein bisschen am Norden.
Krankheiten. Ja, natürlich, aber ich muss sicher gehen und rausfinden, was die haben.
Ja, deswegen bin ich ja da. Was machen Sie noch für ein Zusammenhang?
Ja, aber vergesst dann, Entschuldigung, eine, einige Frage stellen. Ja.
Noch mehr Fragen. Ich dachte, dass sie schon...
Ja, leider sind sie unter Herzkrankheiten, zum Beispiel, fühlen sie sich manchmal
Herzrasen oder Stoffen.
bisher habe ich am Herzen nichts gehabt, nein.
Okay, danke. Okay.
Ja, wird gedauert.
Warteln Sie mich auch der...
Untersuchung machen.
Ein paar Minuten machen wir Untersuchung.
Was machen Sie?
Ich möchte also so als Blut abnehmen, ja.
Okay.
Dann nach einer Ultraschallerei, Weinbruschhörung.
Und sehen wir uns, wie es geht, ja.
Mhm.
Wenn die Ultraschallerei alles erkennen, oder was?
Ja, schon.
Es reicht, ich denke.
Natürlich kann ich, wenn ich gegebenenfalls,
kann ich auch andere wildgebende Verfahren durchführen,
aber ich denke, es reicht schon.
Sie meinen, okay, da ist ein Ultraschall ausreichend, okay.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist das?
Ich erzähle Ihnen noch, ja.
Muss sich operiert werden, Herr Doktor?
Nein, aber ich denke, vielleicht ein Gefäserangiografie können wir durchführen, ja.
Was ist eine Angiografie, Herr Doktor?
Das ist eine Untersuchung, modernen Untersuchung,
Methoden, so die Gefäsen, ja, die Gefäsen.
Also, das heißt, wie wird das gemacht,
werde ich dann aufgeschnitten, oder ist es eine Operation?
Keine geschnitten, kann sein,
Ihre Leistungsbereich, aber Sie fühlen sich nicht etwa.
Das ist nicht eine Operation, ja.
Das ist nur eine kleine Eingriff.
Sie fühlen gar nichts, das tut wenig.
Na ja, das werde ich mir noch überlegen.
Machen Sie etwas zuerst in Ultraschall.
Also, nach dem Ultraschall,
wir sprechen mir darüber, ja, wieder.
Okay, gut.
Das ist ein sehr ausschöner Doktor, aber mein Name ist Osehn.
Ja, ich habe mehrmals Osehn gesagt.
Osehn, bitte.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Genau.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Jawohl, Herr Doktor.
Sie sagten, dass Sie von vielen Arsten untersucht wurden.
Welche Untersuchungen wurden durchgeführt?
Welche Behandlungen wurden gegeben?
Man hat schon eine Ultraschall-Untersuchung gemacht.
Eine Computertomographie hat man gemacht.
Ein MRT hat man gemacht.
Welche Diagnose gestattet wurden?
Soll ich das sagen?
Im MRT haben die gesagt, ich habe einen Bandschein gebrochen.
In der Ultraschall-Untersuchung haben die gesagt,
ich habe Verkalkungen an meine Bauchschlagader.
Und im CT hat man auch Verkalkungen gesehen.
Und wohl auch eine Engstelle an der Hauptschlagader.
Bevor es sich verzweigt in die Beingefäße.
Andere Kollegen fragen,
haben Sie Taubhauts in den Beinen?
Ja, habe ich ja gesagt.
Auf Logiz-Kite.
Wie viele Meter laufen Sie?
Ein paar Minuten.
40, 50 Meter.
Was ich vergessen habe, im MRT,
dass ich auch eine Spinalkanal-Stinu habe.
Sie haben nicht gut gemacht.
Diese Notfallstation.
Und dazugeben würde ich gerne,
bitte gerne gehen.
Herr Doktor, was ist Ihre Bedachtstiagnose?
Ja, das ist die Diagnose.
Das ist eine Diagnose.
Oder die Diagnose.
Ein AVK kann es auch sein.
Wenn die Orte abdominal ist.
Es wird sehr stark verkalkt.
Dann ist ein zentrales Gefäß.
auftreten. Das ist wichtig. Also sie hat starke Verkalkungen, sie hat Stenosen und einigwahlte
Diagnose AVK mit entsprechenden Beschwerden. Differenzial Diagnose wie sie sagen, Spinalkader,
Stenose, Bandscheibenvorfall. Oder eine, vielleicht Anklosen. Ach so, wegen der Rheuma, ja,
das stimmt. Danke, Lösanz. Die Rheuma hat schon eine richtige Rheuma.
Okay, das machen wir jetzt. Die Präsidentin hat eine AVK. Was machen wir jetzt? Wir schicken
sie zu einem Angiologen und schauen, wie hochgradig ist die Stenose und wahrscheinlich muss diese
Dame operiert werden. Genau, wir brauchen eine Angiografie oder ein Angiocet, das heißt ein
CT mit Kontrastmitteln, wo wir die Gefäße darstellen können und wahrscheinlich wird sie ein Stand
brauchen. Sogar ein doppel, ne, wie heißt es, dann Y-Protese vielleicht. Mal gucken, je nachdem,
wie stark die Stenose ist. Genau. Haben wir einen Angiologen unter uns oder eine
Schroden, die wissen es sicherlich besser. Ich bin ein Algemeinschroden, aber Gefäße.
Sind Sie ein Algemeinschroden? Okay. Ein paar Mal schon gesehen. Wenn sie Schroden sind, woran
muss man Differenzial Diagnostischem und auch denken? Differenzial Diagnose.
Solche eine Patientin, also kann man auch.
Knochen, das ist ein Bewegungsapparat. Bewegungsapparat, noch ein Metastasen natürlich oder andere
Metastasen im Form, klar, können oder peritonell, kerzenose, ich weiß nicht, ob es machen kann, aber auch
solche maligenden Erkrankungen muss man natürlich auch denken. Genau, eine Antikorbulatio
und eine lehmenslange Antikorbulation oder eine Antitrombozytentherapie, das heißt Aspirin oder
Aspirin oder eine soziale, sicherlich eine duale Plätchenhemmung, Aspirin und Klopidogrel oder Aspirin,
Aspirin, Tika-Grillor oder Aspirin und heute vielleicht noch Zarelto, macht man auch noch,
AVK oder Beninco, mindestens. Also auf jeden Fall eine duale Hemmung der Gerinnung.
Eventuell auch Norakian.